before we go a very important
programming note
two interviews with former president
barack obama that you'll see only
on cbs this morning we're glad we can
say that the former president sits down
with me
for cbs sunday morning and then scott
pelley for 60 minutes
both interviews will air this sunday now
these are the former president's first
tv interviews
following the 2020 election and before
the release of his new memoir it's
called a promised land
the conversations will cover mr obama's
political rise and his time in the white
house and will also get his reaction to
the election and his hopes for the
future
he's got a lot of hopes check your local
listings for times in our area
so the the book the memoir promise line
is over 700 pages
1 a.m
he has a lot to say and that's volume
one he has a lot to say volume one
that's all you want me
but i think it gives you some really
good insight into his thinking yeah
and why he does what he does and how he
became who he became so i'm really
looking forward to yeah
right after this good luck with that
we're looking forward to it
and everything he has to say given
what's going on